1971 un manifeste circulent le nouvel
observateur le publie 343 femmes
s'accuse du délit d'avortement
je me suis fait avorter ce titre c'est
celui d'un manifeste publié le 5 avril
1971 il ya tout juste 50 ans des femmes
connues ou non déclarent publiquement
avoir eu recours à l'avortement
pourtant interdit en france à l'époque
parmi les signataires les actrices des
écrivaines ou encore l'avocate gisèle
halimi là la vérité c'est que toutes les
femmes à voir ci contre les femmes de
députés et les maîtresses des ministres
et tout le monde soit ne le disent pas
et nous lisons et moi je lui ai dit je
crois en liège nous avons été les
premiers dans le magnifique mais 343
unis
cette pétition c'est un appel à la
légalisation de l'ivg et g au début des
années 70 les femmes veulent se faire
entendre
elles manifestent pour l'émancipation
des femmes et notamment la légalisation
de l'avortement comme ici à paris où
elles sont des centaines à défiler en
novembre 1971
environ 2000 femmes souvent jeunes
quelquefois plus âgé des fils de la
république à nation à l'appel du mlf
le mouvement de libération de la femme
un autre événement marque les esprits
marie-claire une lycéenne de 16 ans a
avorté après un viol
l'afer est très médiatisée son procès
s'ouvre à bobby la jeune femme est
relaxé sa mère condamnée à 500 francs
d'amendé pour l'avoir aidée à avorter
mais aujourd'hui c'est parce que
l'europe
oui on a mené un grand parent c'est sûr
si vous aviez à porter un jugement ce
que vous venez de faire les autres
filles est ce que vous recommenceriez
bien sûr que je recommencerai je suis
très heureuse pour moi mais tout le
monde en profitera nous continueront
pour toutes les femmes
quelques mois plus tard nouvel appel à
dépénaliser les vg
le 3 février 1973 331 médecin signé un
manifeste
là encore dans le nouvel observateur
tous revendiquent avoir pratiqué un
avortement
malgré l'interdiction de la loi
française être pour la liberté de
l'avortement
cela veut dire que chacun puisse décider
en fonction de ses propres convictions
en fonction de sa propre situation
tous ces appels finissent par être
entendue le 26 novembre 1974
simone veil alors ministre de la santé
monte à la tribune de l'assemblée
nationale son discours marque un
tournant
son projet de loi sur l'ivg et j'ai
aussi je voudrais tout d'abord vous
faire partager une conviction de femmes
je m'excuse de le faire devant cette
assemblée presque exclusivement composée
d'hommes aucune femme ne recourt de
gaieté de coeur à l'avortement
il suffit d'écouter les femmes la loi
veil des pénale du vg elle a été
promulguée le 17 janvier 1975
[Musique]